un duro invierno en edlib debido a las
severas condiciones climáticas dos bebés
murieron en el bastión de la oposición
siria la agencia humanitaria de la onu
dijo que las dos niñas murieron en el
hospital especializado al rahman que
lucha por tratar a los pacientes
especialmente a los niños ante las
cálidas temperaturas el mal clima ha
agravado los problemas humanitarios
preexistentes
el hospital está intentando en la medida
de su capacidad acoger a los pacientes
actualmente tenemos entre 100 y 120
ingresados mientras que disponemos de
unas 70 o 75 camas con
[Música]
la trágica muerte de las bebés resalta
la grave situación de los desplazados
sirios en el noroeste ya que las
temperaturas extremas hacen que las
condiciones en los campamentos sean
miserables según naciones unidas según
la onu unos 28 millones de desplazados
viven en el bastión de la oposición tras
huir de la guerra civil de más de una
década en el país
respuesta al deceso de los dos pequeños
la organización es save the children
dijo que en muertes como estas son
evitables es incomprensible que
cualquier niño se enfrente al invierno
temiendo por su vida casi 11 años
después del inicio de la crisis en siria
parece que todo el mundo se ha olvidado
de los niños en el noroeste de síria
ante la falta de ropa de invierno
combustible para la calefacción y la
escasez de fondos las organizaciones
humanitarias piden más apoyo desde
principios de año al menos otros tres
niños han muerto los campos de
desplazados internos